seize mille morts londres et dublin
s'apprête à signer demain accord
historique pour mettre fin à la violence
en irlande du nord
l'émotion est toujours vive à
garges-lès-gonesse après une affaire de
racket à l'école la vitesse journal
monsieur bernard salles mesdames
messieurs vont choir entre 15000 et 25
mille morts la ville d'armero à 200 km
de bogota en colombie est complètement
noyées sous la boue depuis hier soir une
nouvelle coulée de boue tout à l'heure a
provoqué la fuite des secouristes
l'origine et la catastrophe c'est tout
simplement le volcan nevado del ruiz
le volcan est entré en éruption depuis
quelques semaines il a réchauffé les
parois montagneuses des pilotes qui ont
survolé la région par ce soir
d'apocalypse gérard passe
c'est au plus noir de la nuit que des
torrents de boue se sont engouffrés dans
les rues dans les maisons de la petite
ville d'armero ces images sont les
toutes premières qui nous soit parvenue
elle nous montre des drames individuels
qu'il faut malheureusement imaginer à
l'identique à des milliers d'exemplaires
aux premières lueurs du jour les
sauveteurs trouveront des survivants
encore réfugiées en haut des arbres
ensuite lorsque la boue ce sera
complètement est allé dans toute la
vallée d'armero pourront véritablement
commencer les recherches
la rivière l'agonie à fertiliser cette
région de colombie
la nuit dernière c'est elle aussi qui
l'a ravagée presque entièrement en
charriant la mort depuis les pentes du
nevado del ruiz
parfois ce n'est pas un cadavre que l'on
extrait de la boue mais un rescapé par
miracle
ce sera le cas pour ce jeune homme
repéré dans les champs par des
villageois
un secteur de 10 km sur 20 a été
déclarée zone de désastre quatre mille
corps ont déjà été dénombrés mais
l'armée colombienne estime que l'on
pourrait en compter finalement de 15 à
25 milles le nevado del ruiz qui culmine
à 5400 mètres semblait endormie sous ses
neiges éternelles depuis près de 100 ans
sa dernière véritable folie remonter
même à 15 100 95
mais les spécialistes internationaux
savait que pour les vallées voisines
le danger restait celui non pas d'une
éruption mais d'une réactivation du
magma qui suffirait à faire fondre les
glaces et les neiges de tout le massif
c'est ce qui s'est produit la nuit
dernière et le volcan avait pourtant
prévenu en février dernier des
fumerolles l'avait alerté notamment les
français de bogota et en septembre des
cataractes étaient apparues au point
qu'à paris le 7 octobre dernier le
délégué aux risques majeurs avait
proposé l'aide de la france
mais l'inquiétude des colombiens s'était
estompée au fil des jours
hélas il est vrai qu'il ya cinq semaines
notamment à la suite ce qu'on avait
tirer comme enseignement de l'éruption
phréatique qui a eu lieu le 14 septembre
dernier sur nevado del ruiz j'avais à
nouveau attirer l'attention de
l'ambassade de france en colombie sur le
risque très élevé qui me semblait
résider au niveau de ce site volcanique
et éventuellement sur la possibilité
pour 12 d'apporter une aide en matière
de surveillance et d'investigation
ils étaient rivaux d'avoir raison trop
tard après l'événement catastrophique a
eu lieu toujours et c'est pourquoi je
dis qu'au fond on n'a pas réellement
raison parce que sans doute si nous
avions insisté plus et si nous avions
été plus alarmiste
aurions nous pu peut-être éviter que des
milliers de morts soit décompté ce soir
il faut en même temps rester très
modestes ce rappellerai simplement que
le dernier la dernière catastrophe
d'origine volcanique aussi encore plus
meurtrière qu'on est connu dans le monde
remonte à 1902 c'était la montagne pelée
c'était 28 mille morts c'était en france
les pays riches n'ont pas le droit de
laisser comme seul horizon aux pays en
difficulté une récession sans espoir une
phrase du discours du président
mitterrand à rome devant les
représentants de 158 nation ceux ci
étaient réunis à l'occasion
40e anniversaire de la haye fao
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture
la france a dit monsieur mitterrand
fourni 0,15 cent de son produit national
brut aux pays les moins avancés
un taux préconisée par les nations unies
une déconvenue pour la france le
gouvernement ouest allemand ne
construira pas satellites militaires
d'observation avec votre pays
le chancelier kohl avait annoncé sa
réponse françois mitterrand la semaine
dernière mais elle n'a été révélée que
ce soir les gouvernements de londres et
de dublin devrait signer officiellement
demain un accord historique c'est
l'avenir de l'ulster ce n'est pas la
première fois que les deux pays tentent
de trouver des solutions pour régler la
crise de l'élan du nord pour l'instaurer
charte impose qu'on peut dire en tout
cas c'est que le secret bien gardé
oui un secret gardé pour des raisons de
sécurité ce qui est sûr c'est que la
grande bretagne ne re ne sera pas à sa
souveraineté sur l'irlande du nord
ce qui est sûr aussi c'est que cet
accord doit donné à dublin un droit de
regard sur l'administration de l'irlande
du nord
ce qu'en revanche on ne sait pas encore
c'est jusqu'où ira ce droit de regard en
particulier s'il permettra de peser
réellement sur les décisions ou si
simplement ce sera un rôle consultatif
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
d'accord qu'on dit historique déjà
pourra mettre ça à la violence dans ce
pays qui délivre ici longtemps bien sûr
faut l'espérer ce qu'on peut dire ce
soir c'est qu'aussi bien madame thatcher
que monsieur fitzgerald ont intérêt à
réaliser un bon accord tous les deux
sont à quelques mois d'élections
difficiles et sur le plan intérieur ils
n'ont pas eu des succès notamment dans
le domaine du chômage
alors pour l'un et pour l'autre le
rétablissement de la paix en irlande du
nord serait donc une bonne chose
reste que cet accord n'aura pas des
partisans et qu'on peut craindre une
réaction très vive des extrémistes de
ceux qui accuseront bien sûr long de
lâcher l'irlande du nord et de ceux qui
ne voit qu'une seule solution est
immédiate
la réunification des deux irlande cet
accord historique monsigny défaite
diplomatique de lurs à new york par une
majorité sans précédent l'assemblée
générale des nations unies a condamné
l'occupation soviétique de l'afghanistan
la résolution présentée par le pakistan
a obtenu 122 voix pour
19 contre et 12 abstentions le boycott
du charbon sud africain par la france
est de nature à créer des troubles en
afrique du sud
c'est en tout cas l'opinion de monsieur
zac de beer le directeur général du
groupe géant anglo american qui est de
passage à paris
néanmoins messieurs deby reposent que le
partage du pouvoir dans son pays est
inéluctable il expliqué à gilles dijon
chez il ya deux sortes une action qu à
pretoria doit mener la première est
d'achever le démantèlement de
l'apartheid
le gouvernement est en train de changer
certaines lois de ségrégation raciale
mais il reste de très importantes ils
sont toujours en vie elle doit être un
projet le plus tôt possible
mais d'un autre côté pretoria doit
prendre à bras le corps le problème du
partage du pouvoir entre blancs et noirs
et louati y avoir lebouteux possible des
conversations entre les dirigeants des
deux communautés sur la meilleure façon
de régler le problème
vous avez rencontré les dirigeants noirs
du congrès national africain le
mouvement anti apartheid qui est
interdit en afrique du sud
c'est des gens raisonnables
ce sont des gens avec qui on peut
discuter c'est certain nous avons pu
confronter facilement nos points de vue
et ainsi nous comprendrons mieux
naturellement ils ont des perspectives
qui diffère très largement des nôtres
final il est finalement en l'an 2000 qui
gouvernera l'afrique du sud selon vous
les blancs ou des noirs je crois qu'il y
aura un gouvernement dans lequel toutes
les communautés seront représentés mais
je pense qu'il est raisonnable de
s'attendre à une majorité de ministres
noir je crois que la règle de la
majorité devrait s'exercer à travers une
structure fédérale
il devrait y avoir une loi
constitutionnelle garantissant la
liberté de chaque citoyen et protégeant
les droits des minorités
cela signifie t'il l'adoption du système
un homme une voix
personnellement je crois que chaque
personne doit avoir le droit de vote
étant entendu qu'il existerait les
garanties constitutionnelles que je
viens de mentionner mais pensez-vous
réellement que les blancs d'afrique du
sud sont prêts à accepter de telles
perspectives
j'ai pas mal de doutes là dessus j'ai
peur qu'il soit très difficile de vendre
de tels idéaux blanc d'afrique du sud
je peux seulement dire qu'il y en a
beaucoup en parmi nous qui sont des gens
modérés ils ne soutiennent pas le
gouvernement
ils ne sont pas des révolutionnaires non
plus et nous continuerons à essayer de
faire que nos idées modérée soit un jour
partagé par le plus grand nombre
possible de blanc et de noir en france
entre 0,3 et 0,4 pour cent des hausses
des prix pour octobre c'est la 10
provisoires de l'insee si tout va bien
sur 12 mois l'augmentation ne serait pas
supérieure à 5%
ce serait là le meilleur résultat depuis
1971 un écolier de trésors brûlé à la
main par quatre jeunes racketteurs une
tentative de viol une institutrice de
maternelle devant ses élèves
cela s'est passé à garges les gonesse
dans le val d'oise deux faits divers qui
relance la polémique sur la sécurité
qu'elles aient les hr consent de l'école
des fois on se fait taper par les plus
grands clubs et des fois il y en a qui
veulent de l'argent et on leur donne pas
il me kaba ce qu'il faut et louis lemay
découpé dans la gueule et coups de poing
sous sarko bruno 13 en sortant de son
csc retrouvé à l'hôpital pour n'avoir
pas eu d'argent à donner à ses
agresseurs les quatre grands lui ont
brûlé une main à l'essence en
représailles
en moyenne deux agressions sur trois
duos raquettes sont graves mais il
s'agit des établissements les plus
difficiles
situés dans les grandes zones urbaines
il y à là tout une question fondamentale
celle du la dégradation de la société du
chômage de l'école de l'échec de du
manque de formation des jeunes qui a
inévitablement sur ceux qui sont les
plus faibles des conséquences graves au
niveau de la délinquance
je vous envie de sortir ils ont envie de
se payer de la sape les parents et
enfants tous permet de leur payer bon
alors il se procure de l'argent parc et
le racket des petits entre dans cette
logique
ce type de violences restent souvent
inconnus car les enfants rançonner se
taisent traumatisé moyenne d'âge des
agresseurs 14 15 ans mais cette
délinquance juvénile n'est pas toujours
motivé par l'argent dans ces cités
dortoirs où l'on s'ennuie
certains jeunes s'attaque à l'un des
symboles de la société représentant d'un
pouvoir les enseignants moi récemment
j'ai reçu une claque par un adolescent
de 17 ans ensuite nous avons souvent des
crevaisons de pneus des feux cassés aux
voitures évidemment nous ne pouvons rien
faire à cela parce que ce serait pendant
les heures de cours et nous ne sommes
pas présents et il faut absolument
réagir par seulement les enseignants
parce que nous ne pouvons rien faire
seule c'est pas possible il faut pas
oublier que nous sommes pas là en tant
que flic mais nous avons un rôle
éducatif à jouer et on peut pas le jouer
seul sans les parents sans les aides de
la ville ce n'est pas possible
à garges-lès-gonesse une polémique s'est
engagée sur un renforcement des
effectifs de la police mais elle ne peut
pas grand chose contre ce racket discret
en train de les sens et le duo peur
punition n'est pas toujours efficace
peut-être faudrait-il plutôt sans
dramatiser apprendre à ces jeunes par le
dialogue que jamais la violence lui que
devenir banal si les délits liés à la
drogue sont en hausse dans les
établissements scolaires à paris en
revanche la criminalité générale a
baissé de 2,7 pour cent l'année dernière
dans la capitale
c'est le préfet de police qui l'a
annoncé tout à l'heure alors monsieur la
stasi bons choix dans l'opposition crie
haro c'est la politique du gouvernement
particulièrement en ce qui concerne la
sécurité des citoyens
quel est votre commentaire sur ce
chiffre sur la baisse de la criminalité
dans la capitale par exemple les
statistiques en matière de sécurité sont
à prendre avec beaucoup de précaution
cela dit s'il est vrai que la
criminalité générale a diminué à paris
je m'en réjouis tant mieux mais il
faudra que la baisse soit sensible et
qu'elle se prolonge pendant quelque
temps pour que les français
les parisiens la circonstance et le
sentiment que l'insécurité recule pour
que recul le sentiment d'insécurité que
ressentent beaucoup de français bernard
stasi lorsqu'on parle de violence on
associe le mot immigration et je sais
que ça vous fait rire les jeunes
hurlerait pas mais effectivement cela
m'indigne parce que cela ne correspond
pas à la réalité des choses
ou du moins il faut expliquer il faut
expliquer que si l'on compare la
délinquance entre un échantillon
d'immigrés il ya un échantillon de
français même âge même sexe mêmes
conditions de vie le pourcentage de
délinquance le taux de délinquance n'est
pas plus élevé chez les immigrés que
chez les français alors on entre en
campagne électorale l'immigration va
être le thème central en vendée battre à
droite et à gauche c'est bien c'est très
mal c'est très mal je suis très inquiet
parce que nous n'aurons
quelque chance de régler progressivement
les problèmes posés par l'immigration
que si nous les abordons dans la
sérénité
est ce qu'on pense à nous en faisons un
thème d'affrontements partisans eh bien
ce sera une catastrophe
alors ce qu'en dit l'udf et le rpr est
ce que ça me satisfait je crois qu'il
faut pas faire l'amalgamme il y as au
sein du df comme hausse induit repères
heureusement un certain nombre de
responsables qui s'exprimaient avec
modération et le souci de la vérité et
sans verser dans la démagogie mais je
constate et je regrette qu'une partie de
l'opposition dit n'importe quoi sur le
problème de l'immigration et sa ligne
tout à fait sur les thèses sur les
positions du front national ce qui est
incohérent
parce que les français ne comprennent
pas que l'on refuse l'accord avec le
front national ce qui est bien si par
ailleurs on est d'accord avec lui il est
là une attitude tout à fait logique
absurde
en tout cas vous êtes vous bien dans
l'opposition ah je suis bien dans
l'opposition vous souhaiter la victoire
de l'opposition souhaitent en
laboratoire la plus large possible de
l'opposition en 1990 un peu de politique
fiction si vous êtes ministre de
l'immigration quelles sont les
propositions vous ferai après mars 86 et
bien j'essaierai surtout de calmer le
jeu je n'annoncerai pas de solution
miracle j'essaierai d'expliquer à mes
compatriotes ce que d'ailleurs
j'essaye de faire depuis quelques temps
et notamment par le livre que j'ai écrit
sur ce sujet et que c'est un problème
qui mérite d'être examinée à partir de
données objectives et sans en faire un
thème d'affrontements entre les
formations politiques
on rentre chez soi les étrangers chez
eux bien sûr que non
c'est absolument stupide il faut aider à
partir ceux qui veulent partir il faut
aider à le faire de bonnes conditions
c'est à dire développer la politique de
retour et sur ce point tout le monde est
d'accord il faut intégrer ceux qui sont
présents ce qui suppose un effort de
part et d'autre il faut que les immigrés
et la volonté de s'intégrer et qu'il
respecte les lois de la france et les
valeurs dominantes de la société
française et il faut que
les français acceptent d'accueillir ceux
qui vivent chez nous et qui ont
parfaitement le droit d'y rester une
dernière question vous êtes donc député
udf vous appartenait au groupe cdf et on
vous classe évidemment comme barriste
car on ne cachait pas bien sûr votre
soutient raymond barre regretter qu'il
n'y ait pas deux listes avec deux labels
raymond barre non je ne regrette pas
nous avons été tentés de faire des
listes barriste mais il nous est apparu
que cela aurait été interprété comme une
division de l'opposition et donc je leur
est affaibli l'opposition et donc nous
participons à des listes soit udf soit
d'union de l'ensemble de l'opposition et
pour la cohabitation bien pour ce qui
concerne la cohabitation est évident que
le fait que nous soyons sur des listes
avec des hommes et des femmes qui vont
participer au gouvernement nous impose
des devoirs
nous pouvons être par principe je le
suis nous le sommes contre la
cohabitation se dire souhaité que le
président de la république s'en aille
si la gauche est battu parce que cela
voudrait dire que le présent de la
république est désavoué et qu'il n'a
plus l'autorité politique et morale pour
exercer ses fonctions
mais s'il reste et s'il ya un
gouvernement de cohabitation
il est évident que ne pourront pas lui
compliquer la tâche que nous ne pourrons
pas le prendre en sandwich comme audio
football entre la gauche et nous ne
pourrons pas lui mettre des bâtons dans
les roues mais c'est à dire merci une
démission qui va faire du bruit sans
doute celle de monsieur claude jouve n
le président du crédit commercial de
france une banque nationalisée en 1990
c'est la quatrième démission au moins de
quatre on a ironisé monsieur lévesque
l'ancien président du cce selon monsieur
lévesque on ne peut mieux démontrer les
méfaits de l'introduction de la
politique dans la gestion des
entreprises
justement monsieur lévesque lui a choisi
de faire la politique qui se présentera
à paris aux prochaines élections
législatives
sa campagne a déjà commencé d'ailleurs
dans paris eric firoud a rencontré
mecelec cette affiche les parisiens vont
l'avoir souvent dans les mois qui
viennent c'est celle de jean maxime
lévêque qui va conduire une liste
indépendante d'opposition à paris et qui
emploie les grands moyens pour se faire
élire aux législatives 4000 affiche une
vague par mois jusqu'en mars une
campagne retentissante pour un homme
plutôt discret jusque là
la dernière fois que jean maxime lévêque
a vraiment fait parler de lui c'était en
82 lorsqu'il a démissionné avec fracas
du crédit commercial de france qui
venait d'être nationalisées financier de
renom
il n'a pas encore connu la même fortune
en politique peut-être parce qu'ils se
démarquent du rpr et de l'udf contre
lesquels il a d'ailleurs la dent très
dure
avant 1981 voyez vous nous avions déjà
le socialisme de socialisme rampant et
je ne vois rien dans les parties les
programmes des partis politiques
d'opposition actuelles qui permettent un
changement profond dans ce domaine il
n'y aura aucune création d'emploi avec
les programmes qui ne sont proposées le
chômage continuera à se développer et
dans deux ans ou trois ans nous nous
trouverons devant les mêmes problèmes
les mêmes difficultés encore
considérablement aggravée je suis le
changement qu'on ce libéral convaincu
ce serait par exemple de mettre un chef
d'entreprise à la tête du ministère de
l'économie et des finances d'ailleurs si
on le lui proposait après mars 86 il ne
dirait sûrement pas non d évident que
les problèmes financiers et économiques
doivent être confiées dans l'avenir
n'ont pas encore une fois à des
fonctionnaires qui ne connaissent pas
les réalités profondes de notre pays
mais à des hommes qui ont eu
l'expérience de l'entreprise paie et
avec jean maxime lévêque aux finances
les dénationalisations serein rondement
menée les dénationalisations importante
pourrait être terminé en 2 ans très
facilement
reste à savoir si jean maxime lévêque
atteindra la barre des 5% qui lui
permettront d'être élu ça y est la
saison littéraire est revenue premier
prix décerné aujourd'hui le grand prix
du roman de l'académie française décerné
à patrick besson
cantrill roman une valeur de 50 mille
francs a été attribué à patrick besson
pour son roman sahara par 13 voix contre
11 voix à françois olivier rousseau pour
son roman sébastien jaurès
alors patrick besson et critique
littéraire à l'hebdomadaire le point il
a 29 ans son premier roman il a publié à
18 ans le personnage essentiel de son
dernier livre les abeilles qui les jo on
le renvoie en fait à sa mère oui enfin
non pas vraiment oui dans la mesure où
sa mère était hugo scav mais il ne faut
pas qu'elle surmonte un reportage sur
les origines de besson c'est plutôt en
fait est un vrai roman c'est à dire que
des fours à poser leur garde six
personnages sur la même femme et tu
verras c'est d'abord cette petite
bourgeoise qui dans le bagnolais des
années 60 confectionne au noir
des robes et puis on remonte en 200
pages vers son enfance en 1930 est
agréable entre temps chaque témoignage
vient bousculer des formes et esquisse
que l'on venait de se fa de cette
créature
on ne sait plus très bien où l'on en est
on se laisse prendre à ce récit cocasse
ironique et tendre qui décape en douceur
les masques de gara d'autant qu'il y à
toutes les femmes essence de
l'immigration yougoslave dans le paris
d'après guerre avec des figures de
bandes dessinées macro et tueur fou
monnayeurs et révolutionnaire un monde
en apparence des lib le mans et projets
à la petite couturière de bagnolet même
si elle révèle à l'époque d'assassiner
tito en fait
dara raconte superbement ce qu'on a le
plus de mal à admettre c'est que rien
pas même un pouvoir de séduction peu
banale ne peut vous protéger contre la
médiocrité
il suffit de se laisser faire par la vie
une bonne mesure le temps et l'oubli
deux mois si dieu dont pourraient
souffrir les otages au liban
c'est pourquoi le comité des amis de
jean paul kauffmann et les travers
l'événement est organisé ce soir à paris
une réunion de solidarité avec les
otages
à la mutualité kaufmann et sera sont
détenus depuis six mois et diplomates
marcel car comme marcel fontaine depuis
huit mois
les etats unis sont favorables à une
transformation graduelle du système
monétaire international voilà une
déclaration du secrétaire d'état adjoint
américain au trésor
washington aussi a reconnu la semaine
dernière la surévaluation du dollar par
rapport aux autres monnaies un dollar
qui n'a pas beaucoup bougé aujourd'hui
martine chievo le dollar est resté
pratiquement bloqué toute la journée sur
ses niveaux de la veille en effet les
marchés des changes attendent les
résultats des réunions qui se tiennent
simultanément à paris washington et bal
sur la réforme du système monétaire
international
à la bourse de paris les investisseurs
français ont multiplié les prises de
bénéfices sans que cela soit inquiétant
puisque les étrangers ont continué
d'acheter mais on a été quelque peu
impressionnés par le renforcement de la
guerre commerciale franco américaine qui
risque de toucher les exportateurs à
wall street la séance de ce soir était
nettement meilleure que celle de la
veille l'annoncé d'un recul des ventes
au détail a été amplement compensé par
le règlement du problème de la dette du
trésor américain qui ne reste plus la
cessation de paiement
les résultats du quartz hic c'est qu'on
a aujourd'hui à vincennes les enquêteurs
se sont distingués il fallait jouer le
13 las le 2 et le 8 qui rapportent dans
l'ordre 700 587 1028 froid et dans un
ordre différent 48 1819 francs
le temps demain des brouillards au lever
du jour de l'aquitaine au centre et au
nord-est sur toute la moitié nord ouest
dans couvert et faiblement pluvieux au
sud sud est en particulier il fera c'est
beau comme d'habitude
les températures elles resteront
inférieures aux normales
excepté près des côtes de la manche
mesdames messieurs merci de votre
attention de m'asseoir soir trois
premières éditions sera diffusée à 19
heures présenté par richard tripot pour
la deuxième édition ne nous retrouverons
à 22h35
bonsoir je vous rappelle les titres de
ces journal une
une deuxième coulée de boue en colombie
plus de 15000 morts
peut-être un accord historique de main
sur la lande une entre londres et dublin
patrick besson grand prix du roman de
l'académie française cours darah
bernard stasi hier soir fois une parti
d'opposition du n'importe quoi sur
l'immigration